today i got asked a question that nobody
has
ever asked me before and it [ __ ]
stumped me
i was talking to a friend of mine on the
phone i was interviewing him we were
doing a little interview from me
and i asked him a question i'm sure he's
been asked a million times he's a gay
guy and i asked him i said when did you
know you were gay
and he told me and then he asked me a
question nobody's ever asked me before
at the end of the interview he said to
me
when did you know you weren't gay and i
was like what
he goes what was the moment and i was
like
was there supposed to be a moment
so i started to think about it i'm like
was there a moment
and i think there was and i bet you it's
the same for most straight guys
the moment you realize you're not gay is
when you're a teenager
and you're masturbating and you get uh
you look down at the wrong time and you
get a little bit of your own calm on
your face you're like i don't [ __ ]
like that at all
you know that you know it's happened to
all of us one point in time
that hits your face you're like i'm not
on that team that's not my team i don't
like that [ __ ]
yeah you know it's funny i told my
brother i go yeah man
he goes yeah that happened to me twice
dude i go twice
yeah i knew i didn't like it enough the
first time where i was like that [ __ ] is
not happening to me again that means you
leaned into it the second time
[Music]
[Music]
you